welcome to this video plenty m cassoulet
yeah I'm he has a name in there but I'm
totally unable to to pronounce that
French name do Russell or something I'm
terrible okay I'm not even trying to get
that right okay let's play this an
Italian game it's gonna be up with you
three that's the modern way to play that
didn't get some quick moves in yeah why
does not earn castling here sometimes
this is played to play a quick g-form ok
I'm going to mmm ok interesting d 5
maybe maybe I can just go d5 here why
not Oh
that's a bit uncommon that's only d5 and
taking but certainly okay how do I play
that I would love to play b5 Bishop c4
and somehow trap is queen but that's not
going to happen rook da does a move that
I can definitely play will also make
sure is not simply canceling long so
easily hmm
champ Knight a5
Chad do I play g6 here and maybe I do
okay let's not be fancy about it and to
be content with a solid equal position
that I definitely have here a check the
night maybe I could have done something
more ambitious there I don't know the
night on edge for looks a bit iffy okay
now Quincy five is the move to just just
be okay yeah let's do that not come into
big-time pressure i'm a little bit
behind on the clock IAM yes guys high
rated but i have a good score against
him + 35 wins two losses and two draws
ya hear I should definitely be all right
about equal this position
okay okay did not think you would cancel
any man but probably had to cancel a mp3
I try to do it without castling Jackie
yeah minor piece end game I have no I
have no complaints about my bishop is
the better PCM compared to his bishop it
so it's not much however he is probably
trying to go to d5 so I'm going to get
the King up to d6 try to be quick about
it okay b5 before I smile my plane
trying to get at his well try to get him
to play even more here on the the light
squares or a 4mm before he has before
which should be okay mmm I wonder ever
should try to should start with the move
I think I should start with that and
then think about it a little bit more
yeah yeah this is an interesting moment
I was thinking midnight a7s may be
interesting trying to go to be five
interesting yeah let's try that looks a
bit artificial maybe you can just play
Bishop d3 here and maybe yeah maybe I
should have just taken night before or
something yes that's definitely possible
now
not good snow that's not that's not good
how I played that probably tink
and 9b five in this position 493 later
he also has this check on c4 which is
really really annoying or can take
now I played that it was it was too
hastily played him I was ambitious here
and I should have reconsidered this a
little bit more before I go for it I
started with the better end game and
this is probably a bit worse at least a
bit worse maybe more i'm not quite sure
94 i will take and play 93 am i taking
h-zyme Jim Janet that sets the the
critical line I guess attacking a 2 + B
form a 4 is 0 is a move that's very
critical I cannot take it on pass all
and he gets this pawn going yeah I have
to check i have to check before can i
play you see five rooms letting him
advance them a little bit c 5 a-5 f6 SEO
hi honey that's probably a really bad
idea to allow that but the point is kind
of on its own I don't know maybe this is
completely bonkers giving him that and
not take form maybe possibly a very bad
idea
night eh for could be the problem
amongst others em and it was a very
risky idea that was my idea that I'm now
able to play 96 and possibly get at the
pawn but but yes night receive form king
put King d3 I can play Queen King b6
maybe I can play that King c4 maybe if I
go nitey 60 place nights you form let's
wait for a moment check
yeah Kings is 69 f 6 how do i get get
get to get to him here like this maybe
my d3 check check and he's covering them
okay check
check nice too quick black fly offense
on time used to quick now I killed
myself in the end game here out of them
this is just a little bit better for
black at least a little bit better okay
I think this is probably still okay
right here tell maybe this was a bad
idea i don't know maybe I should play
slowly him I don't know that's a bit too
ambitious maybe tell I was maybe too
ambitious I can I should be a little bit
more patient may be in this position and
not play before which I can play anyway
I should maybe think about some pieces
then the knight on c6 is still not great
and they have some ways to improve here
like f six or so I have a little bit
more space and the better bishop it's
probably not amounting to much but the
only way to lose the game was really too
yeah go for go for what I did probably
check check yeah and now maybe I should
just take it for this this is a very
risky decision quite clearly yeah yeah
I'm okay of course but I don't I don't
think I should lose but it's difficult
it really is yeah maybe I should I
should just take em probably check ticks
ticks and 94 Kings you for why don't
they go to why don't I go to hear
because I probably didn't want to run
into the channel right
check where it's still nothing
particularly grateful white the 92
threat is very substantial here that
side that I did not see that I'm that I
can go for this square where I have 90
to check now that's of course a little
bit whether the time disadvantage gets
problematic you simply cannot or at
least I cannot be so precise then here
black assam again granny better my pawns
is just quicker I get a good idea for
next yeah okay but in those endgames
mistakes are bound to happen from both
sides but that means maybe my play was a
bit risky here giving him the a porn but
it wasn't bad particularly I just I just
played to change museum this is a
strange move why would why pervert
integral should be six it's kind of
strange but I still get to the same
thing yes this is the this is there this
is the mistake really and still it wrong
pic yeah computers always completely
merciless but this is just stronger I
did not see that I have the check here
which would net me the pawn and
basically forces him back he cannot
allow 92 and me taking the porn here yet
I have a drawing hand by the way I can
always go here and be better McKee end
going back Cham that was a totally
unnecessary yes she again I can go and
just just keep things that's a draw yeah
okay that was really sad necessary check
and here the the upcoming age peso it's
just far too strong okay interesting
though thanks for watching